John Grisham is known as a master of the
legal thriller yes look at that 30
consecutive number one New York Times
fiction bestsellers he's sold more than
300 million copies of his books
worldwide and now he's out with his 25th
legal thriller he calls it the rooster
bar it explores a world of for-profit
law schools through a group of students
who learned that their school is owned
by a shady hedge fund operator John
Gresham joins us to the table this is
the second time in IRA's Nora pointed
out two a year for you mr. Gretchen twos
too many ones and that one's enough yeah
next year just one when they're like
this I don't know if two is too many but
I know when they're good keep them
coming let's talk about the rooster bar
because the genesis was as I understand
it you read an article in the Atlantic
and you thought what that made you think
this is this was an investigative piece
by Paul Campos it was published three
years ago in the Atlantic and somehow
stumbled across it and I was not
familiar with for-profit law schools and
I was not really familiar with the
student debt crisis and the article
really opened my eyes and it was it was
a great piece but it was also a
troubling issue and I started
researching and the novel was quickly
born from that you know it's interesting
as you point out the American Bar
Association says there are currently six
for-profit law schools in this country
with accreditation one of them is the
Charlotte school of law which recently
closed their problems closed in August
mm-hmm they have problems for a long
time not all the schools are shady a lot
of success stories from these schools
but the the levels of debt that these
students incur and then they pass it off
as in the form of high tuition to people
who are making a profit and that just
struck me as being wrong and the high
number of the debt - I was surprised and
I assume that you researched those as
real figures two hundred and sixty six
thousand dollars one hundred ninety one
thousand dollars well Gail my research
is always shaky don't believe everything
you read okay but now those numbers are
not far off you can bar seventy five
thousand bucks a year for three years to
go to law school
40,000 50,000 goes to the for tuition
goes straight to them to the owners of
the law school yeah and you can borrow
twenty thousand bucks you to live off of
so that's seventy five thousand dollars
a year you can borrow for easy without
giving a whole
Holloway though to tell people you you
essentially have some number of students
in the book and they're facing a
mountain of debt and they go after the
hedge fund operator who's making a
profit then well they can't they can't
find jobs which is fairly accurate with
a lot of these schools
lottie's graduates their prospects of
passing the bar exam or rather Dilma and
was in a great school it's not a great
school
what's foggy bottom law school what's a
real name foggy bottom I didn't make
that there's a law school at Foggy
Bottom by the way it's a very good law
school are you going to Princeton
tomorrow do they look at the F scott
Fitzgerald manuscripts Camino Alan came
out back in June I was here you folks
had and we had a good visit the book
came out and we had not contacted
Princeton before the publication this
book was about that it was about
stealing the manuscripts with Princeton
library and I didn't go there I didn't
see the library I just claimed all of
that I don't know I don't know what my
normal research I wanted to but I was
advised not to not to warn Princeton
that this book was coming and I didn't
there's nothing nothing actionable like
they can't do anything about it so I
didn't warn them and about a month or so
after the book came out I got a very
nice letter from the head librarian at
Princeton saying we love your books and
we love this book once you come visit us
yeah so I'm going tomorrow to see the
Fitzgerald manuscripts and to speak on
campus that's looking forward to that's
not to do can I point out in your books
you never have a preface I actually like
that why do you not have a preface in
any of your books well I just don't like
them normally they don't work a prologue
or a preface when you start it's it's
sort of gimmicked a lot of writers used
to do something really dramatic to get
your attention to get you sucked in and
then they move away from it and leave
you hanging yeah and that's just not the
way I tell stories I like to start with
you know the first chapter and the end
of chapter 14 know flashbacks nothing
fancy just a direct storytelling you
know we just had Jeff Fager here and 60
minutes which is investigative reporting
is about telling a story you tell
fictional stories what's at the heart of
a good story will conflict suffering
injustice romance well I don't do sex
very well
why not exactly sex is good John Gresham
most me cannot write sex okay all right
oh yeah
oh well yeah most men cannot write good
sex okay and I tried one time years ago
to my wife laughing okay we're we're
hitting a hard wall
why are we talking about sex I'm thank
you so much good let me do a hard wall
here guys that's relation to the target
when we get off in game found not guilty
rooster bar is on sale today your why do
I keep this morning